en la última serie de ejemplos llegamos
al segundo mes con 100 dólares en
efectivo y la forma en la que expresamos
este ejemplo es que gastamos 200 dólares
en el segundo mes y como lo hemos hecho
hasta el momento ustedes podrían decir
bueno en nuestro balance de efectivo
vamos a tener menos 100 dólares y lo
cierto es que esto es muy poco realista
aquí puse un balance en negativo de
efectivo simplemente para mantenerlo
sencillo pero normalmente no se ven
balances negativos de efectivo cuando
vemos este tipo de elementos quiere
decir que alguien nos ha prestado algo
de dinero y para hacer ese ejemplo un
poco más realista vamos a imaginar la
siguiente situación que en el mes 2
tenemos 100 dólares de efectivo y la
persona a la que estamos dándole el
servicio por la que estamos teniendo
estos 200 dólares de costos y ya que no
nos va a pagar hasta el siguiente mes no
es necesario que se le diga a la gente
que se gastó todo esto podemos decir que
tenemos estos 100 dólares tengo este
cliente al que le estoy dando el
servicio por lo que puedo pagar 100
dólares por este mes y pagar otros 100
dólares el siguiente mes y digamos que
nuestros proveedores están de acuerdo
con esto por lo que en el segundo mes
con respecto al efectivo en lugar de
estar gastando 200 dólares voy
y gastar 100 dólares y en el tercer mes
voy a gastar otros 100 dólares y con
esto va a cambiar nuestra contabilidad
del efectivo ahora este número será
menos 100
aquí serán ahora 500 dólares pero lo que
quiero que vean es como esto se puede
contabilizar en nuestras cuentas por
pagar el hecho de que ustedes le hayan
dicho a sus proveedores que incluso
cuando les hayan dado 200 dólares en
productos ustedes solo van a pagar 100
dólares ahora y se les pagarán los 100
dólares faltantes el siguiente mes
ustedes incrementaron sus cuentas por
pagar en 100 dólares pues ya que le
deben algo a otras personas vamos a
agregar la línea de cuentas por pagar
acá vamos a agregar otro renglón lo
pongo abreviado sé de cuentas por pagar
por pagar y en este periodo
no teníamos ninguna deuda ninguna cuenta
por pagar
y en este mes donde esencialmente
estamos tomando prestados 100 dólares de
nuestros proveedores
y aquí vamos a tener una cuenta por
pagar de 100 dólares no voy a trabajar
con los siguientes meses por el momento
pero ahora vamos a ver cómo nos afecta
en nuestro estado de cuenta de ingresos
en nuestra hoja de balance aquí tenemos
otro elemento por pagar las cuentas por
pagar son pasivos así que tenemos una
cuenta por pagar como pasivo de 100
dólares utz perdón aquí no tenemos
todavía pasivos de cuentas por pagar es
hasta al final del mes donde tenemos
nuestro pasivo de cuentas por pagar de
100 dólares por lo que aquí nuestro
efectivo es de 0 noten que esto no
cambia nuestro patrimonio neto quitamos
el menos 100 de efectivo y agregamos
nuestras cuentas por pagar de 100
dólares ahora tenemos que todos nuestros
activos son de 400 menos 100 de pasivos
nos van a quedar 300 dólares de
patrimonio neto esto no cambia pero
ahora nuestra reconciliación es de pasar
de 100 dólares en efectivo a 0 dólares
en efectivo evitando tener números
negativos aquí y la razón por la que
podemos hacer esto es porque tenemos una
fuente de efectivo
tenemos una fuente en efectivo por lo
que vamos a borrar esto y agregamos una
línea aquí abajo
veamos si la puedo agregar aquí cuentas
por pagar incremento de las cuentas por
pagar y esta es nuestra fuente de
efectivo aunque puede que esto no sea
obvio pues estamos incrementando
nuestros pasivos pero es una fuente de
efectivo ya que no tenemos que usar
nuestro efectivo quiere incrementar las
cuentas por pagar nos permite no usar
todo nuestro efectivo así que tenemos un
incremento en las cuentas por pagar de
100 dólares
ahora el efectivo de las operaciones son
200 dólares de ingreso neto menos 400
dólares más 100 dólares todo esto va a
ser igual a menos 100 dólares
este es nuestro efectivo de las
operaciones comenzamos con 100 dólares
usamos 100 dólares y nuestro efectivo al
final es de 0